okay so how about your special your
special was shot at the Wilbur Theater I
know the Wilbur Theater it's in Boston
yep uh that's where I got my accent are
you still you still like doing shows in
small towns
you mean that's obviously like going to
the cities but do you like going to like
small towns and doing shows yeah I love
I love just being on the road I like
just um
even with friends I I went with my
friend uh my friend Leslie was given a
car by her mother
um you know and so she needed to drive
from Texas to Los Angeles and I thought
that sounded like a good time so I said
yeah I'll go with her to pick up the car
and we're going through West Texas and
there's nothing out there and we had
been just eating trash just
just shoving trash into our faces the
whole trip and
um and she said oh I think I have a
great great great great great great aunt
that lives in West Texas maybe we can
crash with her so she called her dad she
hooks up this situation where we're
going to stay with her great great great
great great great aunt and we arrive at
one in the morning and you think this
old
woman's going to be in bed
she's pacing by the window just waiting
for our arrival we I know it's a sad
story and uh and we go in just wanting
to go to bed stuffed with junk
she's cooked the equivalent to a
Thanksgiving feast for us oh really guys
this is a funny story
we're so tired and then we have to sit
up and eat turkey legs and and cranberry
relish the whole the whole pie yeah sure
she made pie and uh
and then we have to sit and hear about
people we've never met all of her
friends are dead and like we guys what
did I say and you were warned this is a
very funny story
and uh and then we were finally heading
off to bed just to get some sleep and
then whoa
she fell what guys it is a comedy
she fell hit her
hurt her hip and then we had to take her
to the hospital and okay
thank you
then we're at the hospital all night
with her yeah
all we wanted was a place to crash yes
and now we're up eating pie and in a
hospital with this woman and then we
just get her fixed get her hip fixed and
then we just get back on the road and
drive to Los Angeles exhausted so next
next time you're just going to hit a
motel right well we wanted to save forty
dollars
worth it